hey there everybody welcome to today's
caress a career coach career chat our QA
to help you move forward in your job
search and help you achieve your career
goals we're gonna be giving it a few
minutes here for folks to join us on
YouTube so take this time to share out
the link to any friends or coworkers or
anyone else in the world that you know
who's searching for a job right now
we're excited to really dig in today to
our topic which is going to be about
navigating the job search as an
introvert and navigating networking as
an introvert more specifically and then
we will open it up to all of your
questions we've got Karen in the chat
she will be collecting all of the
questions that you'll be sending our way
over the next hour sending them over to
me and I'll be answering them one by one
so thank you again for joining us got a
little bit of a change of scenery right
now I'm in a in the white void of our
satellite office and I'm excited to you
know catch up with you all and see where
you're at with your search you know give
a shout in the comments right now where
in the world you are I'm in Chicago we
just survived the polar vortex and then
had a 50-degree weekend where I ran on
Lake so it's been an absolutely crazy
turn of weather over here today it looks
foggier than London town and it's gonna
be a really interesting week in Chicago
where are you joining us from I'm gonna
jump into the comments and take a look
all right we got San Jose
we got warm temperatures in rural
Georgia we got snowy Seattle raining in
Delhi India got some nice waves coming
in Sun we got uh Abu Dhabi yep I was
running on the lake I'm not sure who
you're making that comment for Karen I
Lake Michigan I am based in Chicago good
catch there Columbus Ohio and boy is it
rainy sunny in Jax India India Romania
boring weather in Romania I'm sorry to
hear but I guess it's better than you
know getting frozen into a polar vortex
all right we got Egypt Morocco Ghana
Boston the Taj Mahal welcome I India
India India Pakistan Nebraska thank you
all for joining we got a great turnout
coming in today I'm looking over here
because I'm staring at my phone looking
at all your comments all right we got
some digital marketing questions coming
in we've got snow in Colorado Mexico San
Jose again our topic today is going to
be out-of-network as an introvert but of
course we can expand this to cover any
topics that are on your mind from
building your online presence to
interviews and so on one note as we get
into the conversation today I am a
career coach and I'm primarily in my
background is primarily in marketing
career development and how to basically
build social skills and put yourself out
there so people can see you notice your
work and want to bring you on board my
knowledge in the technical realm while I
do am able to go into some high level
areas when it comes to the technical
aspects of the job search like
whiteboarding and things like that I
will say I am not the developer so
coding and those super super technical
questions might be just outside my reach
so if we want to focus on the main
things and I'm able to help but you'd
help you with that's great if some
technical questions come up we'll try
and help you answer those in slack or in
the chat with each other and you know
just giving you a heads up in case I
don't touch on
super super technical stuff I appreciate
you all joining us today I'm super
excited to hear where you're at with
your job search and see how I can help
you take things to the next level we're
about five minutes in and we've got a
good turnout here so I'm gonna start
jumping in to our first topic all right
we got main and here we go Oh India all
right gonna jump on in how do you
network if you're an introvert
this is a really interesting question
that we want to dive into because we
know that a lot of folks who are in our
student body and our alumni alumni
groups they struggle with this concept
of introversion and extraversion and
there's a typical mentality around
networking that if you're not an
extrovert
you really shouldn't or you're not
capable of getting out there meeting
people and building you know building a
life in though in the world you're in if
the world you want to go in with your
career it's going to be you know it's
it's potentially a little bit more tough
to get out there and do those things if
you're not naturally inclined to go to
social events but it's definitely not
impossible and I want to point out a
couple of things as we think about
networking and being an introvert
heading into our job search the first
thing that you want to keep in mind is
that most of the world is introverted
and it's not actually a bad thing I was
reading a stat recently and it said that
40 percent of the world is shy 40
percent of the world used to be shy
and 20 percent of the world isn't shy at
all which means the bulk of the world is
shy most people find it awkward to go
interact with large groups of other
people so you're absolutely not alone in
your introversion and in your resistance
to wanting to network one of the things
early on in my career that
I had to get over was my introverted
nature and I am more of an introvert
than an extrovert I'm kind of on the
border but I tend to skew introverted
for the most part especially the older I
get and I used to have a lot of anxiety
and an even panic attacks before going
to events or going on interviews and
things like that but what you find over
time and this is something called
exposure therapy for all of you people
who love psychology out there the more
you expose yourself to situations like
networking events and things like that
the easier they get over time the less
scary the less of a hill it is to climb
over so what you want to do is realize
that it's okay to be shy the other thing
is that the other forty percent so it's
40 percent shy forty percent used to be
shy and twenty percent isn't shy at all
is that that bulk in the middle used to
be shy so I would say that I used to be
very shy and now I'm in the used to be
shy side of things and so you can
develop the skill and move from shy to
use to be shy we might not never we
might not ever get to the point where
we're like you know the life of the
party but we can definitely build our
skill set and that's really what it is
is a skill set around networking now the
other thing that I want to point out is
a lot of us think about networking as
sales we have to go out there we have to
ask for the job every single person we
talk do we really have to just like go
after it but the truth of the matter is
networking is about building long-term
relationships around the topics that
you're interested in so it's not about
you know if you meet someone that at an
event the chances that that meeting is
going to immediately turn into a job
within the next week is very very slim
but what it can do if you do that over
and over and over again for months and
months and months is build a long that a
strong network of lots of people who are
doing the things that you like to do and
that you want to do so that when
opportunities arise you can call upon
those people whenever
talking to someone and they say I want
to be a front-end developer I ask them
how many front-end developers do you
know usually the answer is none so what
we need to do because of this concept of
the average you're the average of the
five people you spend the most time with
is you have to ask yourself well how do
I meet more people who do what I wish I
were doing that way when things come up
they will pass them along to you there's
actually a great example of someone I
know who does murals she's an artist and
she networks all the time with different
artists and when and because she has all
these people within her network when a
job comes up that someone else can't do
they go into their mental rolodex and
say well who can do this and then things
can be passed along to her it's how you
build a community it's how you help
other people as well later on in your
career if you surround yourself with
people who do what you like to do when
you come up with opportunities that you
can't take on in the future you can pass
those on to those people give back to
your network give back to your community
and one way you can start thinking about
this to make it a little bit less salesy
and a little bit more fun is to start
thinking about networking
not as quote-unquote networking which is
a term that we're not hugely fans of but
think about it more as nerding out we
all love to nerd out about things new
technologies self-driving cars the
future of Education in my case mental
health is something I'm really
interested in how do you nerd out with
more people around the things that you
love to nerd out about make that the
center of the topic for you introversion
is something that can be worked on being
social and going to events is something
that can be worked on but there's also a
whole world of places to nerd out where
you don't have to be there in person
you've got reddit you've got Cora you've
got Facebook groups LinkedIn groups
Twitter you've got Instagram you've got
all sorts of online communities that you
can join and nerd out in and then use
those as ways to talk to people get your
message out there
and find opportunity
these around the work that you'd like to
do so create your online presence if
you're an introvert figure out what it
is you like to nerd out about and then
go out there and build that networking
skill so that you can achieve the career
goals that you hope to achieve
throughout your life
that's our intro on introversion if you
have more introvert questions and
networking questions please put them in
the chat right now and Karen will be
sending in my way so that we can address
all of the questions that are on your
mind all right
jumping on into our first question all
right again I'm learning how to
pronounce names so if I mispronounce
your name I apologize in advance
uncut jewel you J I'm not sure sorry
uncle I have my own business making
websites for other business owners I
have to network with other business
owners should I go to networking events
and if so what kind is a wonderful
question
networking events are incredibly
important to go to but you also want to
be very aware of the types of events
you're going to many events are career
focused so you'll go there and you'll
find people who are job seekers other
events are sales focus you'll see people
going there who are trying to sell you
things some are more social focus you'll
see people who are going there to just
have a good time and maybe relax have a
few drinks after work you need to be
aware of what types of events you want
to go to and chances are if you're
helping business owners small business
owners entrepreneurs build their
websites you want to be going to the
events that they would be going to so
rather than going to like a WordPress
event or a coding event or any of those
types of things go to the event where
or the only web developer in the room go
to the event for you know how to do
sales for your small business everyone
there is a small business owner trying
to learn how to do sales and you're the
person in the room that can help them
build their website to support their
sales process so when you talk to all
those people you're very different you
stand out you can have interesting
conversations that are different than
everyone else there and you can say hey
you're trying to increase your sales did
you know that a great website will help
improve your sales I can reduce the
number of clicks between the person
landing on your page and purchasing your
service I can improve the overall look
and feel so that they actually trust you
more I can change the user experience so
it's better all these different things
so if you go to networking events try
and figure out where your customers will
be maybe you know what industry you're
most interested in so you can go to
industry events maybe you enjoy helping
artists create websites or musicians or
something like that go to music venues
go to art events and art galleries and
talk to them about you know hey I build
small business websites you have you
know your small business as a musician
let's get your let's get you online
let's get you started you know it
depends on your audience and then you
really just want to go there and talk
about their needs and what and what
value you can bring to them if you can
help them make more sales improve their
user experience
reduce the number of clicks and
therefore the number of people who fall
off or give up during the purchasing
path those are all great things to keep
in mind so I really appreciate this
question it's a really great one you
should go to networking events but also
know that most small business owners are
trying to build their online presence as
well so they might have a blog a medium
article LinkedIn pages for sure and you
can go and comment on their pages you
can go send them direct messages you can
go help them on Twitter all the
different places where you can connect
with them as well and actually read it
would be a really great place you could
join some
reddit pages we're small business owners
and entrepreneurs are talking about how
to build their business and then instead
of selling there because reddit tends to
you know not like it when you're very
salesy you could just comment with tips
so they're like oh I don't know how to
build my funnel well here's some web
resources for you so you provide value
there and then they'll seek you out
beyond that all right our next question
is from Varun Rao could you go over how
to build an elevator pitch for a
networking event thank you for your
question beroun this is a great one the
way I like to think about elevator
pitches is going back to this idea from
simon Sinek he SI m o n SI n EK he gave
a TED talk years ago that outlined this
concept of start with Y now the concept
is start with y says that most people
don't want to interact with a person or
a brand because of what they do they
want to interact with a person or a
brand because of why they do it so if
you think about this for yourself why do
you do the thing that you do and this is
the the way that he phrases it is he has
three circles that are within each other
the most exterior circle is the what
everyone knows what they do I'm a web
developer I'm a marketer I'm a X Y or Z
right some people know how they do it
so for let's say a web developer I'm a
web developer and the way that I make
great websites is by bringing a human
centered design perspective to the
websites that I build so my
differentiate er which is the how is
human center
design right so now you have your what
and your how human centered design in
order to be a web developer to create
websites and then very few people
actually get to why they do what they do
why you do what you do is like your
general purpose the thing that you
really want to see happen in the world
so maybe for you you want technology and
humanity to work seamlessly together
right that's the goal of many people who
work in AI that's a goal of many people
who work in augmented reality that's the
goal of many people who work in a lot of
these wearables and things like that so
your Y could be my goal is to improve
the fluidity between people and the
technology that they use to enhance
their lives I do that by taking a human
centered design approach to web
development what and then at the end of
that you say what sort of things are you
working on right so that's your elevator
pitch if someone says hey what do you do
well I help I hope people create amazing
experiences that create fluid
interactions between their users and the
technology that they sell I do this
through a human centered design approach
to building websites and then you say
well what and what are you up to so that
is one way to create an elevator pitch
now there are lots of ways to create an
elevator pitch but what you definitely
don't want to do is tell your life story
and start with well I went to high
school here I went to college here I
just graduated from here and I need a
job can you give me a job that's a
surefire way to have someone not know
what to do and not know how to help you
so an elevator pitch should just sort of
generally set up the type of
introduction and conversation that you
want to be having and then move into
actual practical things that they're
interested in you know what brought you
to this event what are you trying to
accomplish with your business what are
you most excited
about for the future of technology
things like that that make a networking
event and then network and conversation
much more fun all right our next
question is from gem Chang you asked
besides besides events on Meetup what
kind of source can I use to find good
networking events and is social media
networking less powerful than networking
in person these are really great
questions I'm gonna tackle on one at a
time the first one what other sources
exist then meetup calm there's I would
say meetup.com is your best starting
point but beyond meetup calm if you
really can't find anything there try to
search eventbrite.com cuz that's gonna
be another place where you can find
meetups and then look at local websites
that have events in your area
professional organizations tend to have
their own events volunteer organizations
tend to have their own events so you
might be able to find stuff on their
websites but in our day and age of
everything sort of aggregating in one
place all of these companies and all of
these organizations that are trying to
put on events know that people aren't
going to find their website so they
typically try to leverage Eventbrite and
meetup calm as there are two sources to
get the word out
so I would start with those two and if
you really can't find anything
just look up websites to find meetups
and I'm sure there's some other ones
that are not as top of mind for me but I
typically being in Chicago I can go
pretty deep into those websites and find
something to do almost every night of
the week in Chicago I know that's not
everywhere in the world but if you
here's the big thing if you go on those
sites and you really want to be doing
something going to an event
and you don't see it you don't find
anyone talking about that topic what you
want to do is take that as an
opportunity to be the person who owns
that topic it's like finding the
McDonald's URL before McDonald's knew
what URLs were if no one else in your
area is talking about this thing and
hosting events you get to become the
expert so I know someone that worked
with someone who wanted to put on wanted
to go to a sports tech meetup or it was
like people are interested in sports
people who are interested in technology
didn't exist they created it themselves
they started talking to CEOs and
inviting them to speak and it led to a
lot of big opportunities to work at
companies so I would highly recommend if
you don't see it build it now on to your
second part of the question is social
media networking less powerful than
networking in person this is sort of a
it depends kind of a question I wouldn't
say it is less powerful because I've
seen people get jobs on Twitter I've
seen people get opportunities through
Instagram and I've seen someone even
learn how to network or even tap into a
network through their clash of clans
slack group which I never would have
thought was the thing
where's in person it takes up a lot of
time a lot of energy you might go to an
event and not meet anyone useful I think
they both have their pros and cons the
goal is to become part of the
conversation
networking isn't just about meeting a
person and ask me for a job it's about
providing value to the overall
conversation that's happening around
this topic so if you want to be part of
the you know WordPress developer world
there are lots of WordPress developers
they're all doing stuff there's lots of
customers that need WordPress developers
and they're all looking for resources
and if you're one of the voices that
exists in that space you're going to
have a much easier time getting clients
getting opportunities finding companies
to work for so I wouldn't say either is
more or less powerful than the other and
it also depends on your skill set some
people are absolutely amazing in person
what I do
is that an in-person meeting leaves a
much stronger impression than an email
back and forth because you have facial
expressions you meet each other you
shake each other's hand so my goal is if
I go to an in-person event I try to get
a couple of names and then meet those
people later for a one-on-one coffee
because when you're in a group and
there's a lot of activity people tend to
forget who you are so take an in-person
meet up and turn it into an individual
conversation in person then take the
individual conversations and turn them
into online connections where you
connect it on LinkedIn then you can be
posting on LinkedIn and sharing things
and commenting on each other stuff and
now you have an online relationship with
that person which then could you know be
refreshed in person every once in a
while and then eventually when something
comes up and you're able to collaborate
on the project together or for each
other for a job that can happen online
in person etc so I'd like to think of it
more as like a badminton game between
online and offline rather than one being
good and the other not being as as
strong so I would say figure out what
you're best at first and then try and
leverage the two against each other I
hope that kind of gives you enough to go
on but of course ask more questions in
the comments if you'd like to go deeper
thank you so much for your question
all right Gregory networking question
I'd like to create a meetup group and
organize events around deep learning and
self-driving cars how do I find people
interested to talk and/or organize
events with me
awesome question Gregory this is going
to be an area where we just kind of use
the resources that exist there are
conversations happening everywhere on
the internet around these topics so if
you're putting on an event around these
two topics go create your meetup go
create your Eventbrite go do whatever it
is that you're doing and then interact
on Reddit Twitter Instagram YouTube and
anywhere else that you can find people
who are already having this conversation
you can tap into companies and have them
be speakers at your events and have them
shared out with their networks and you
can tap into volunteer organizations and
professional organizations as well I'll
give you an example a while back maybe
two years ago I wanted I I had this
little blog idea called career dogs and
my concept with career dogs was career
advice with a dog spin it was just a
goofy idea I felt like creating a
website once I created the website and I
wrote a couple posts I wanted to put on
an event because I just thought that
would be super fun I wanted to play with
some dogs I wanted to talk to some
people about the careers so I created an
event called career dog therapy and
career dog therapy was just a way for
people to come together basically
complain about their jobs and then play
with a bunch of dogs that will make them
feel happy about things again it was a
very goofy idea right but I was talking
to someone at the American Marketing
Association and they thought it was
super fun just a one-on-one coffee that
I was having with this person I brought
up the idea and I said hey if you ever
want to collaborate I think it'd be a
really fun event
we ended up collaborating we got we work
involved we put on the event and they
shared it out to all of their network at
the American Marketing Association we
had a great turnout probably twenty
thirty people not sure I think we had
about four or five dogs show up it was a
really fun event
and I was able to help people with their
careers we were all able to pet dogs fun
all around and I did that by tapping
into their network so try and tap into
networks that already exist rather than
trying to build everything from scratch
provide value say hey we have this great
event would anyone like to speak offer
opportunities to people with who are
trying to build their platforms maybe
you can go on YouTube find the top 20
people in your area who talk about these
topics and say hey would you like to
talk about this at my event youtubers
are trying to get seen they're trying to
get more followers so play into that
play into people's personal interest and
and flatter them you know and so you can
really attract a lot of eyeballs by just
partnering with the people that are
already way ahead of you at pulling in
attention and then how do you get them
to organize and work with you I think
you just reach out and you just are
honest like hey I'm really excited about
putting on this event I'm looking for
venues I'm looking for people and you
know if you just put it up on maybe
Craigslist even I'm looking to organize
an event is anyone interested probably
better on reddit but you know you'll be
able to find people out there for sure
also go follow go look up these terms in
hashtags on Twitter on Instagram and in
the LinkedIn content search you can look
up these hashtags and find people who
are already in talking about these
things
all right prod to it I'm so sorry if I'm
pronouncing all your names wrong you
asked a question which is I have a fear
of people judging me so I I look sorry I
have a fear of people judging me and I'm
really insecure when I approach people
for networking how can I get over that
it's funny because as you're asking me
this question I have an extreme fear
about mispronouncing people's names and
the only way through it is to do it I'm
you're just going to mess up and and
have to keep going at it and this is
something I think I mentioned a little
earlier in the conversation it's called
exposure therapy try and find the
easiest least scary form of networking
to start with maybe it's tweeting
someone maybe it's emailing someone
maybe it's commenting on people's posts
which is even less of a scary thing than
emailing or tweeting someone start
building the skill the practice of
interacting with other people and this
fear of being judged is totally you know
common and totally understandable I have
it as well quite a bit one of the
reasons I don't make more content than I
want then I'm currently making is
because of that fear you know I need
things like this to really instigate and
push me to create more content I know
people are expecting it so now I got to
do it right so you just have to sort of
number one accept where your app with
things don't try and pretend that you're
something more than you are you are
someone and you're admitting it here you
have this fear of being judged so let's
start small let's just start with the
practice let's not worry about the
outcomes let's not worry about any of
the other things let's just start with
the action and the prayer
this how do I number one just have a
conversation about these topics maybe
start with friends that you have right
family members things like that branch
out into commenting on posts and just
incrementally and slowly build your way
up hopefully that will be helpful I took
I that's kind of how I started was just
small incremental improvements over time
and then at a certain point I just
dedicated myself to jumping all in and
allowing myself to fail I think one of
the one of the ways that I've gotten
over a lot of insecurities is by having
a really bad experience and then just
knowing that that was the worst
experience everything will get better
from this point on I actually at one
point went on an interview purposely
without preparing just to see what would
happen when I'm completely unprepared
and now what that's helped me do is be
able to take on situations where I'm
less prepared than I'd like to be
because I know I've done it before and
I've built the skill of how to wing it
and how to how to maybe improv my way
through it then that a conversation
could have gone worse but it just ended
up being a thing where it's like wow
this is a lot of effort and a
conversation that didn't go anywhere in
a job that I didn't get and if that's
the worst situation everything else is
uphill from here I think I also joined
improv classes and there's a number of
other things like that including public
speaking things like Toastmasters I'm
not sure where in the world you are
right now but there are lots of
different ways to build your let's say
resilience or antifragility around these
topics because you know at the end of
the day being able to hold a
conversation with a stranger is going to
be super important for the development
of your career whether it's dealing with
clients new employees new co-workers and
so on you want to be able to build at
least the level of skill you need to get
what you need to to accomplish in your
life
again you don't need to become I don't
know Gary Vaynerchuk or one of these
like online entrepreneurs who's the most
social person on earth you just need to
get to the point that's good for you and
gets you the results that you need in
your career so I hope that that's
helpful and when it comes to the idea of
other people judging you that's gonna be
something that is an internal practice
of you know confidence building and
understanding that at the end of the day
most people are worried about you
judging them more than they are judging
you and so when you're looking at
everyone and you're like they're
spending all their time you know
assessing me and judging me the truth is
everyone else in that room is in their
own head worried about how everyone else
in that room is thinking about them
we're all too self-absorbed to really
worry about you or anyone else so when
you can sort of take a step back and
realize everyone is in their own head
for the most part and most people aren't
actually thinking about me or care about
what I'm doing like put yourself in the
networking event you're standing in the
corner of the room you're looking around
you're scared I do this all the time I
just stand there and don't talk to
anyone and I think everyone in the room
is looking at me right no they're not
they're looking at the the food they
have in their hand the drink they have
in their other hand the handshake
they're trying to do the conversation
they're trying to have they're worried
that their shirt might be untucked or
their hair might be messed up they're in
their own head they are not looking at
you and when you go up and talk to
someone they're worried about the words
coming out of their mouths they're not
worried about you so I hope that helps
just kind of take some of the pressure
off and then everything beyond that is
repetition and practice and exposure and
just putting yourself out there in the
ways that you are both expanding your
comfort zone and not like you know
putting yourself in harm's way or
anything like that or in and in truly
dire situations which is pretty hard
when it comes to networking so I hope
that you can incremental improve over
time
all right our next question
Ihab Hamdi I'm very shy talking with
people but I but today I decided to talk
to people at an event and it was a nice
conversation but I feel I committed many
mistakes for example I just started the
conversation about my project idea
without introducing myself I'm looking
for tips when first engaging in a
conversation and have it end it
gracefully this is a wonderful question
thank you for sharing when it comes to
making mistakes and this is something
that probably I learned most in improv
and learning how to give talks and
presentations and things like that the
worst thing you can do or they're
probably the toughest thing the toughest
mindset you could give your you could
have going into a conversation is
thinking that there is a correct way to
do this right so if we think we have to
do this and this and this and we have to
do it in this order and we make we must
touch on these topics what's gonna end
up happening is we're going to spend so
much time in our own head we're gonna
forget there's another person who's part
of this conversation
a good example of this is whenever you
meet someone at an event and you shake
their hand and then they just go off
talking about all of their work and
their projects and their other things
and they never talk or ask you any
questions the truth of the matter is if
you worry less about yourself and you
take that focus and put it on the other
person asking them questions asking them
what they're interested in it what
they're excited about what they're
struggling with what they hope to learn
from this event where they think their
careers going if you just ask them
questions and say nothing about yourself
the whole time you're talking that
person is going to have loved this
conversation with you because the truth
is people don't really care about anyone
else except the things that they're
working on it might be a little harsh
but that is I mean when you allow
someone's space to talk about themselves
their interests they feel good and so if
ever you're at a loss make it more about
them than about you and then when it
does come back to you you say you've
made a mistake that you just started the
conversation talking about your project
idea without first introducing yourself
now I know that feels like you made a
mistake but that person is probably
interested in your project to some
degree maybe it relates to something
they're working on so just in the future
you're already catching these things so
you've done it you've identified areas
where you want to become where you want
to refine it let's say and now next time
you do it just give it a shot again if
you do this again the wrong way again
then the next time just give it a shot
again you were going to meet hundreds of
thousands of people throughout your
career so you have hundreds of thousands
of opportunities to mess up and to still
improve I bet you that the conversation
wasn't so bad that they were like upset
and walked out of the room right they
weren't mad at you you just feel like
you weren't complete in your
conversation right so here's a here's a
way you can rectify it after the fact
okay you leave that conversation you
forgot to mention a couple of things you
wanted to mention
reach out to them via email because you
have their card I hope reach out to them
via email and say hey I had a great
conversation with you I'd love to
continue it and learn more about your
work
over coffee we should be open tool to
grabbing to having a coffee chat in a
couple of weeks now when you go into
that coffee chat you've got more time
more space and more of a relaxed
situation where you can talk about
yourself a little bit more and talk
about the things you're working on a
little bit more and then when how do you
end things gracefully boy that's a tough
one it's really hard to get out of the
conversation sometimes some good ways to
do it are to say like I'm gonna go get a
refill
it's been wonderful meeting you maybe we
can catch up later over coffee do you
have a what's the best way to keep in
touch that way you're like you know
hang up the conversation you say it's
been a pleasure chatting with you I'm
really looking forward to chatting with
a number of people of this event so I
hope you have a great time and I'll see
you around the rest of the event there's
a lot of different things that you can
do to power out of a conversation
but again just you're doing it already I
want to make that very clear that you've
made the decision to go talk to people
so do not be too critical of yourself as
you're learning this skill allow
yourself the space to make a mistake and
then let your subconscious do the work
from there the next time you talk to
someone your subconscious will kick in
and be like remember to introduce
yourself first and you'll catch yourself
next time so just keep it up I think the
fact that you're thinking about it is
already doing what you need to be doing
alright Alexandre where does one start
I'm an introvert and just the thought of
speaking to others is terrifying let's
start with people you know for in-person
networking who have you worked with in
the past who did you go to school with
and who are your friends ask if you can
start by getting coffee by meeting up
with them for coffee even like people
that you've worked with that you don't
know super well just to have some more
familiarity so let's just start there
for the in-person networking and then
for online networking start by
commenting on people's posts on LinkedIn
Twitter blogs etc pick the platform
you're most interested in and start
engaging in the conversation there you
know just in the comments you don't have
to create anything new you just have to
say awesome you know post I really agree
with this
here's another resource that might help
etc etc just try and get some reps
chatting with people online maybe
move that into you know email
conversations or or chats via you know
direct message things like that and
slowly build from there so if the
thought of speaking to others is truly
terrifying try and build the skill of
people you know and then also do the
lowest hanging fruit online and then as
you continue to build your comfort level
take it to the next step up I hope
that's helpful if you have more
questions around that I know it's fairly
general but please please share and
thank you so much for your question
chris has a great question here his
question is how do you get over shyness
at an interview oh boy
I'm not sure that you'll ever get over
your shyness totally right but you can
respond to your shyness in a positive
way most of us respond by closing up and
running away
you know that's at least my my history
with it but what you can do is accept
your shyness accept your nerves and then
continue forward despite them or in
spite of them so the problem with an
interview and what makes interview so
hard is that you have so few of them
when you're searching for a job it's
very tough to get to the interview
portion of a job interview of a job
prospect there's also the phone
interview the in-person interview
technical interviews there's lots of
different types of interviews so how you
get over your shyness I think the best
way to do it is to do informational
interviews lots and lots of one-on-one
coffees that are low stakes because the
real interview is so high stakes our
nerves are through the roof however if
you're just getting coffee with a random
stranger who works in the industry who
if you mess up that conversation look
for bed who you are in a week anyway
it's not a big deal you can meet with
hundreds of people and you can have
hundreds of bad conversations because
there's thousands more to meet with so I
think the best
way to get good at a real interview is
to have a lot of small half-hour
conversations with people who work in
the industry over coffee over you know
tea and just get used to talking about
these topics and what will end up
happening is in those conversations
you'll learn interesting stories that
you tell you'll learn interesting facts
from the people you talk to and you can
take all those things into the real
interview that you go on so that would
be the best way to do it is just google
the term informational interview go to
the Meuse com go to all these different
websites and get good at having coffee
meetings because if you're really good
at coffee meetings you'll be much much
better in a real interview
all right Phyllis has a question do you
have suggestions for networking remotely
I'll be looking for a remote data
analyst position and I live 40-plus
miles away from my potential employers
and like-minded data analysts meetup
type groups this is a great question
Phyllis when it comes to working
remotely your online presence is going
to be incredibly important having a
personal brand having video of yourself
if you can but audio video images you
want to seem like a real person when
someone Google's you if if you're trying
to get an online if you're trying to get
a remote gig because the problem with
getting a remote gig is that they won't
necessarily see you in person before you
start working and so the barrier I'm
sorry the barrier that you're gonna have
to get over is this barrier of trust the
reason people do in-person interviews is
because when you're in the room looking
at them shaking their hand and making
eye contact there is a lot of trust that
is built and then when you sit down and
have a conversation you get to see their
movements you get to see how they
interact with the office the other
employees the people that brought them
in and so on there's a lot of data that
comes
our body language and comes from our
interactions and our tonality that is
lost in a medium like texting texting or
email or things like that so the more
you can do to make yourself a real human
on the internet meaning videos audio a
well a well-oiled website that has your
information clearly shown with your
projects and things like that the more
you can do to humanize yourself online
the better it'll be when you're going
after those remote roles and then what
you need to do is reach out to people
with interesting reasons of reaching out
say at the very basic you know would you
be up for a Skype call I'm curious to
learn more about your work but at the
highest level what you can do is create
amazing excuses to reach out to people
if you have a blog a podcast or a
YouTube channel you can reach out to
people to interview them for your blog
your podcast or your YouTube channel now
you have positive excuses to reach out
that provide value to these strangers
who would otherwise be a little bit
tough to get hold of I'll tell you it's
much easier to say hey would you do a
two-hour podcast with me or one hour
podcast with me than it is to say would
you just jump on skype for an hour if
you do Skype calls that are just regular
Skype calls and they're not a podcast or
something I would say you know fifteen
minutes of their time 30 minutes max and
make it very clear that you know you're
super grateful and one thing someone did
which I really appreciate it I I met
with someone to do like a little chat
coffee as years ago and they sent me I
think like a $5 Starbucks card code via
email as a thank-you afterward so like
there's a lot because they couldn't meet
in person we met on skype they were like
here's that coffee that I owed ya I
don't know it was really cool I thought
that was a great way to do it
all right we have a great question from
ANCA about keyword research tools you
know I have one let me see if I forget
the name of it I'm trying to look my
bookmarks right now gosh what was it
called there's one called ask the people
I think which is a really great resource
for for finding topics that relate to
your core topic like if you're a blogger
or something like that let me see if I
can find anything else here here we go
words stream dot-com slash keywords is a
free keyword tool that might be super
helpful for you it's been a few years
since I've used this but it might be
something worth looking into and then
again use Google to your benefit
just Google Keyword tools and will be
able to find really relevant stuff for
your industry
all right our next question is from
scruffy what is the top of the pyramid
when it comes to networking if will
things moved around sorry what is the
top of the pyramid when it comes to
networking if sending emails and
commenting on posts is the bottom the
top of the network when I are the the
top of the pyramid when it comes to
networking is people reaching out to you
if you are creating content and
providing value at scale online you
don't have to network as much anymore
your social network but not as much as
before because people will see your
stuff and come to you I'm sure a lot of
you who are on this call or who have
engaged with the content that we've been
creating here have noticed that it's
much easier to reach out to me because
you've seen my face and you've
interacted with the content we've
created here then if I didn't do it
because you wouldn't know who I was you
wouldn't know my name you wouldn't know
who I am I've seen a stark difference
between the time prior to making this
video these videos last September and
now in the number of people that reach
out to me rather than me just posting
and hoping someone will see it so I
think the top of the pyramid is becoming
a creator and contributing to the
conversation at scale at such a such a
volume and it's not a huge volume really
anything that you're posting will get
out to people that people are coming to
you to talk about these things a step
below that would be you know having just
strong connections within the industry
if you're regularly going to events and
talk into the people and part of
professional organizations and things of
that sort if you're speaking if you're
doing things like that if you're just
helping host events for large
organizations for a long long time I was
just involved in the Events Committee of
the American Marketing Association
helping
bring in younger people into the
organization you know that was a great
way to partner with a big-name
organization and build my network at the
same time build a skillset build a
network
so yeah the lowest hanging fruit is to
just comment on things and engage with
other people who are posting things and
then the highest level thing is to be
the one who's posting the things and
having other people comment on you hope
that's helpful and this will be our last
question before we wrap up today when
this is from grace from grace beauty
when networking I always feel that I'm
not meeting the expectation of being
smart enough what can I do I love this
question I'm so glad we're ending on it
today because the idea of being smart
enough doesn't actually exist it's like
it's like saying I don't want to post it
until it's perfect
well there is no such thing as perfect
there is no final state of being that is
perfect or a final state of being that
is smart everyone who is intelligent
knows what they don't know which means
there's no end to it every time you
learn something new ten more doors open
up of things that you need to learn so
even with the questions here today right
you're asking me questions I don't know
the answers to all these questions I'm
giving the best answers I've got and
then I got to go do more research I got
to go figure out more stuff because
these are new things that are coming my
way right you will never be
quote-unquote smart enough nothing will
ever be perfect nothing will ever be
complete fully you can always adjust you
can always learn something new
you could always be quote unquote
smarter what's more important being
smart is being curious if you are
curious and you ask questions
networking becomes easy because you
don't have to prove anything you don't
have to answer anything you just have to
go into rooms go up to people and ask
them about their
opinions and then you seem smart by
affiliation you seem smart because you
got them talking about topics that they
feel smart about that's how you come
across as smart when networking and
that's the secret the secret between
being scared of networking and being
super excited to network I guess is to
have lots and lots of questions that you
don't know the answers to so that when
you walk into a room you can talk to
anyone because all you have to do is ask
them a question and let them fill in the
space so for all of you introverts out
there who are worried about having to
fill the silence with your words just
learn how to ask better questions all
right
that's going to be our last question for
today thank you so much for joining us
for our career QA our ask a career coach
I want to get a shout that we have an
event coming up for a tweet chat this is
gonna be on Twitter so not on YouTube
but mark it in your calendars creating a
career you love and guess what day we're
gonna be doing this on oh yeah
Valentine's Day we're gonna be talking
about creating a career you love on to
14 at 1:00 p.m. PST the hashtag is going
to be hashtag Udacity chat again that's
on to 14 February 14th at 1:00 p.m. PST
a time hit us up on Twitter and then
also look at the chat that's going on
right now
Karen's posting a link to join us next
week for another ask a career coach
session here on YouTube where we'll be
answering all of your questions and
diving deep into figuring out how to
crush it in your job search and find
that dream job I hope you enjoyed
today's conversation if you have more
questions feel free to follow us hit us
up on slack it may have on LinkedIn and
we look forward to helping you continue
to crush it in your job search and we
will see you again soon thank you so
much for joining us